最近とった面白い動画は……何だろう……
最近取った面白い動画を見せましょう（ﾄﾞﾔ
ああそうだ…………ハッハッハwwwwww
そうなんかてつやの服が穴だらけだったんで
塩のショットガンで撃ったら痛がりました
はじめしゃちょーです!
いやまだあるぞまだあるぞ
事務所で編集しているAGOですね
横から見るとやはりこの
伝わりますか？（伝わりましたby字幕主）
ビンタしたくなる☆
これは確か……電撃を当てるんですよ
ぬぁあぬぃこれ？　あぁそう……
電撃が走るあれを
よっちの体につけるやつ
つきました。よっちの顔は……
ｱﾊｰ↑
アハハ☆
ンフフ
楽しい毎日を過ごしておりますはじめしゃちょーです
質問コーナァッッ
明日やります（いつの明日とは言っていない）
なかなか静岡に帰ってくる時間がなかったので
ちょっともうしばらくシュクシュクおまちください！
デキレバ！できれば明日出したいと思っています
ので今日は
軽くいきますよ
今回なんですｇ……
アアッ！？　刺さっｔ……
今回なんですけれども
Twitterであるリプライをいただきました
安心してください！
食べなければ、いいんです（格言）
後で誰かに食わせよ
と言う訳でメントスコーラならぬ
マーブルチョココーラというのがすごいという
噂を聞き付けたので今回やっていこうと思います
もうメントスコーラなんてどれだけやっていない事か
お菓子から遠ざかってて全然やってないんですけど
ああもう全然ダイジョブ
もうお菓子の誘惑には全く通じません
もうお菓子に対する精神力が凄すぎて
全然ダイジョブです（ｷﾘｯ
ここ言葉で表せないからだれか助けて
コーラですね
ｺﾞｸｯ
安心してくれ、俺はもう今年は飲むことはないから
と言う訳で今回こちらのマーブルチョコとコーラ
これを合わせたらなんかメントスコーラより凄い
みたいな噂を聞いた
この人もマンガで見たからわかんないんですけど
本当かどうかってのわからないんで
今回実際に確かめてみようと思います
ひとまず一回やろう
一回メントスコーラ方式でやります
マーブルチョコってメントスと作りが一緒なんですよ
ひょっとしたらコーティングの成分的には
マーブルチョコの方が強いのかもしれない
それによってメントスコーラよりすごい爆発力に
なっていくとしたらもう
ﾊﾞﾁｭｰｰﾝ♪
かもしれませんからね！？
行きますよ行きますよ一発ですからね？
行きますよ！ほんとに行きますよ！！
もうすーすーいきますいきますから
懐かしすぎるこの感じ……たまらないZE
３……２……１……
なんか時間差でずっとなってるんですけど
なんか凄いマーブルチョコがここでうろちょろしてるんすよ時間差で
なんかずっとコーラメントス程反応はないんですけど
ずっと弱くずっと反応している感じです
ずっとなんかマーブルチョコが踊ってるみたい
えぇえー！？凄い！
コレ多分……
コーラじゃなくても反応する気がするんですよね
ダイレクトに全部入れちまおう
ｵﾗｯ
さあどうなる……
うわーー全部すごい上がってきた！
凄いんだけど！？
こっちの方がすごいお！
凄い凄いちょっと待って！
なんか激しいこっち凄い
うわ凄いなんか
すごいねぇ……
あぁうきそうで……浮かない
あぶねぇ……
はいと言う訳でマーブルチョココーラやってみたんですけど
も！
ｳﾝ!
ｳｳというかまあコーラメントスとは違う方向的に
凄かったです
ここら辺でマーブルチョコがすごい
浮いたり沈んだり……踊っていたので
幸せな気分になりました（小並感）
後輩『ハイ』
あ、もしもしりょうくん？
後輩『ﾊｲ』
マーブルチョコほしい？
後輩『なめとんのか！？』
ﾍﾟ↓ﾍﾟ↑ﾍﾟ↓ﾍﾟ↑ﾍﾟ↓ﾍﾟ↑ﾍﾟ↓ﾍﾟ↑ﾍﾟ↓ﾍﾟ↑ﾍﾟ↓ﾍﾟ↑ﾍﾟ↓ﾍﾟ↑ﾍﾟ↓ﾍﾟ↑
2016年10月29日午後十時のニュースをお送りします。
羽生結弦がまさかのSP4位で「悔しい」
中国で振り込め詐欺が社会問題化しました。
ミネラルウォーターに発がん性物質が検出され746万本を回収
TBS吉田明世アナが結婚
これで本日のニュースのコーナーを終わります
次回もお楽しみに（予定なし）